from The Wall Street Journal NATO
formally blames sabotage for nordstream
pipeline damage military Alliance says
it would be prepared to defend its
infrastructure from attacks in a
ratcheting up of tensions between Russia
and the West it's a little bit worse
than that they said
NATO said the series of leaks in the
Nordstrom pipelines between Russia and
Europe were the result of sabotage and
that attacks on its members
infrastructure would be met with a
collective response from the military
Alliance so let's just say
they I'm assuming they're not talking
about Nordstrom but they might be
because Germany relies on it but it's a
weird thing because I'm trying to figure
out what they're trying to say okay are
they blaming Russia for it directly no
but several member states are
if they are it's very weird that they're
like our adversaries infrastructure was
blown up and we'll retaliate if someone
blows up our infrastructure it's like uh
it sounds like you blew it up and now
you're worried they're going to blow up
yours so I don't know world war three or
what do you think it's it's not a good
geopolitical situation for everyone
involved here everyone's going to lose
everyone's going to suffer the people of
Europe are going to go without energy
Russia is of course already dealing with
a lot of consequences because of the war
the U.S embassy just announced that any
American in Russia should leave
immediately Putin is also set to Annex
large parts of Ukraine which is going to
set the groundwork for a possible
nuclear attack on territory that now he
claims is his and and again it's a messy
situation it's a very complex situation
we should be calling for de-escalation
and sadly all we're seeing on the
corporate media is escalation putting
more fuel on the fire which is dangerous
for everyone and stupid in my opinion it
looks like Vladimir Putin may go with
the zap bran against zap Branigan
strategy strategy are you guys familiar
where he sends wave after wave of his
own men just into the onslaught until it
completely overwhelms now that's a joke
right but that's actually the
traditional Russian strategy it is
historically right so during World War
II so this is amazing I've got a Soviet
um what is it called I think it's called
the p64 I could be wrong I don't know if
you know this is Polish and it was uh
from the cold cold war it is a small
it's a nine millimeter Makarov it's a
handgun and it's ergonomical only for
your right hand which is okay I guess
it's not inclusive and nobody ever wants
to use it at the range you know why it
bites into your head it hurts and so
it's it's it's fun to have these Soviet
bullets these macro bolts but the thing
is when they were making guns they were
like they don't care if it hurts they
don't care if it's made of crap they're
just gonna make a ton of them and crank
them out and give them to everybody and
say go for it so they met I think I
think the story was in World War II they
mass produced a whole bunch of garbage
tanks and then Germany was like we're
gonna make really good tanks that were
really hard to make and then Raja just
storm through with all them blowing up
and they're like more is better
so yeah it looks like as much as I can
joke about Futurama
we thought with a conscription of 300
000 men and the reporting that he could
even bring up to 100 up to a million
seems like the annexing of the territory
strategy is going to be okay how many
ukrainians are there screw it just send
300 000 guys there and then we'll win
yep well that's all it takes
overwhelming Force that's always been
Russia's main main way of doing things
and they have very little care for human
life in general and that's that's what
we've seen from Putin over and over and
over again that's what we've seen for
almost every government that is true
that is true but especially the Russians
especially the Soviets that's I mean
when Stalin was just you know Mass
murdering people Mass taking people's
starvation they didn't care about the
people he didn't care about the people
on the ground it's what his overall goal
was because it's it's true but I just
don't think that's unique that's true
you know I mean Barack Obama blew a
bunch of kids you know it's not the same
as you know holiday more or anything
like that yeah so there's certainly
people who are substantially course that
I understand but I just think
you know governments this is what they
do World War one was pure attrition it
was just trench warfare against machine
guns but I think but also in World War
one they used to cut underground
underground cables and and mess with
each other's infrastructure so we have
to understand that this was an act of
War what are going to be the larger
ramifications of it or something that is
dangerous for everyone escalations sorry
no no that's okay no I just think the
higher you get up in the in the Escalon
of things High Atop The Thing the less
you care about the people below you
because you don't see them you don't
deal with them you don't you don't see
what they're doing on the ground you
don't see their families you don't see
that they can't pay their bills that
they can't get groceries they can't get
gas I mean it it's all to varying levels
of degrees but as you get higher up in
in power that's that's how people tend
to look at I think about that with like
the opioid crisis too I hear a lot about
people and like oh and his wife got
addicted to opioids and then she died
and part of me is like wow how stupid
she was and then I realized like if that
was my family member and you see someone
suffering from drug addiction it's no
it's like one of the most suffering like
gut-wrenching horrible painful
experiences because it's so helpless
feeling well but that's especially true
because my both of my parents passed
from no opioid addiction we didn't know
that that's what it was back then we got
to remember where we were at that point
when when my parents were taking
Oxycontin it was because the doctor gave
it to them yeah and and so we didn't
know that they were addicted to those
drugs we didn't know that it's basically
synthetic heroin that you know you can
abuse at any given point and so we
thought it was helping them but it was
really killing them right and so we have
to remember where we were in history at
that point we look back on it now of
course we know it's an opioid crisis of
course we know but the pharmaceutical
companies know but they were high Atop
The thing right they didn't care about
the people on the ground they were
making their money I'm looking at
you know it's funny because we talk we
talk about Civil War the potential for
civil war quite a bit and now the lead
stir we have is that NATO is basically
saying we will respond as a collective I
mean this this is this is the door being
knocked on of the NATO military Alliance
saying we will go to war with Russia but
inside the United States we have a
decrepit decaying demented old man as a
president no one most people don't even
believe he's in charge we've got an
opioid crisis we've got a economic
collapse the Market's tanking it's uh I
don't know where this is going but but
but uh I don't is it bad but no Tim
absolutely not we have a great vice
president in Kamala Harris she's a very
strong very thoughtful very intelligent
leader that just signed an official
alliance with North Korea North Korea
will now be fighting officially on our
side according to the vice president of
the United States other statements
earlier on today so in the White House
transcript they struck the word North no
they didn't yeah they said wait did we
actually did she actually sign somebody
no no no no she officially no okay let
me explain this you want to explain this
go ahead no well she she was giving a
speech in front of in front of some
cameras and she said that we have we
have great partners with North Korea we
are great partners with North Korea and
I I think it was more than that it was
yeah she said something like a strong
military oh yes oh yes she was like it
was like she meant to say something yeah
she did yeah she but you still don't
have to strike that from the record they
Struck it there's a line through it
I think I think this is what people are
posting on Twitter I need to fact check
it but you know yeah well what do you do
you should be striking that you should I
think it was uh Daniel Turner actually
who tweeted it out because he mentioned
that uh in the past they've actually
outright altered the transcript remember
when Biden said repeat the line yes they
were like he said let me repeat the line
no he didn't no we all heard him what I
saw that Korean jump here podcast I was
gonna call it that one clip where
they're like the reporters are really
getting concerned with Biden's mental
health they're like dude okay but he you
know he did say top of mind about a dead
person he did say where is he did keep
asking for someone that it was dead
thinking they were in the room like what
is going on well at least he has an
excuse though that's that's what scares
me about Kamala Harris it's like okay at
least it Biden's is an older man right
he's obviously doing a very hard job
it's not hard to be vice president okay
I mean many have said it's not worth the
you know pissing a boot yeah right it's
it's not a hard job but she still has
these very she can't speak correctly you
know you know what meme I really like is
the um
um oh what's that what's that show uh
where Impractical Jokers or something
like what wasn't yeah yeah they're all
laughing the guys backstage looking at
the screen making another guy do
something yeah so like we need to make a
meme of Kareem Jean-Pierre and then it's
the guys like okay now just say a bunch
of random words and then she talks and
then it's them laughing it's like it's a
master of improv she's saying random
things and you're like
look I know the whole thing's a
spectacle but like going up there and
not saying proper sentences is just a
chat it makes me angry and I gotta
control my anger it's a total chat move
every day all she would have had to say
to get past that was go
the president means a lot of people the
president is talking to a lot of people
he didn't remember that that maybe she
had passed away in that moment that's
all she would have had she could have
just said he clearly misspoke yes if she
made an accident accidents happen if she
was like yeah I don't know what's wrong
with them would she be fired the next
time
[Laughter]
you understand Ian like phrasing it that
way is actually like one of the worst
possible ways to phrase it yeah but
would she be fired would she like the
next day would they have a new speaker
if she was no better no no because she
was you know it would be one of the
greatest days in American history no she
should get honest for a minute and save
the Republic could you imagine if
someone a reporter was like just today
the president called out to a deceased
geo-representative why would he do that
something's wrong with him I don't know
what I'm running for president yeah
that's why I feel like a press secretary
Michael malice would be so much fun oh
yes because he just say like something's
wrong with him you know you asked if
like world war three and civil this
these world war three and Civil War
during World War One the Russians had a
civil war so like it can be both at once
that's really what concerns me if that
if some crazy War breaks out overseas in
Europe and Asia as if we think it's
going to stay there that then there
would be chaos internally and it's like
dude you saw the Communist Revolution
brought a century of murder and Decay
and then a split up into what they have
now which is no Black Sea access like
they've had to fight to try and get back
access to the Mediterranean because
after the Soviet Union was split up
whoever the oligarchs were that chose
who got what said no Russia's not going
to get sevastopol they're too strong we
want to block them off from the
Mediterranean but Russia did have uh
that they have a naval base there and so
they were like okay this is part of
Ukraine but we don't care that Russia
uses it and people there speak Russian
that's why Russia moved in and take it
when Ukraine was was entertaining
joining the EU or NATO and they're
trying to give Don bass make it
autonomous at least this is what Dave
Smith was saying on Rogan was the the
word on the street when they were
negotiating a peace deal Ukraine and
Russia is like we're gonna make Don best
the Eastern version of Ukraine
autonomous I don't know if that means
give it back to Russia keep it as
Ukrainian make it its own State make it
independent and no NATO troops in
Ukraine as pre-decided before 2014 after
the fall of the Soviet Union it was
decided we're not going to put NATO
forces on Russia's border because now
Russia's are good now now that the
Soviet Union's gone they can be a
federation to work with us
and um tell me but NATO's NATO's just
been expanding yeah and now they're now
they're now Finland potentially joining
so it's funny because I was reading one
article and it said Russia's unprovoked
invasion of Ukraine and I'm just like
okay first of all that's just an opinion
piece right like unprovoked you can
argue that NATO expansion was a
provocation you can argue it wasn't you
can argue whether or not a country wants
to join NATO Russia still has no right
to invade Ukraine but there's certainly
I I don't know if provocation is the
right word but there are reasons behind
why these things are happening it's not
like this is a complicated matter that
goes back decades and has been
escalating slowly and surely and and
many people saw everything coming many
people saw the writing on the walls uh
Putin is set to give a speech tomorrow
specifically about this uh particular
event about his annexation of now more
Ukrainian territory as his troops look
like they're also losing in a very
important key city of Lyman right now
and it's also important to note here uh
from a lot of the videos and a lot of
photos some of it is propaganda but it
doesn't look like the Russians are
having a lot of military success inside
of Ukraine and when you look at the
photos when you look at the videos it's
it's overwhelmingly a lot of Russian
Hardware being destroyed so you know
just seeing that just just highlights
you know the situations getting
desperate this is a complicated
situation we don't know who to believe
everyone's lying from each side here
there's a lot of disinformation there's
a lot of propaganda and uh it's going to
be interesting to see what he will
announce tomorrow as I will be keeping
keeping a very close eye on it well and
there's a lot of money being made by
replenishing everything that's being
blown up yeah you know and that's that's
that there's a that comes down to it man
it's always hey how can we get more and
more stuff in there more and more
billions of dollars worth of Munitions
so we can put more and more in there
when it gets blown up that's what we're
talking about this pipeline my first
thought was CIA second thought was
corporations like the corporations that
are profiting off of the war right the
the so this new Baltic pipeline who
whoever is running gas through there has
a real good interest in taking away
leverage from Russia but I want to say
one last thing on on this you know look
right now we're dealing with a whole lot
in this country with the with the
hurricane
and uh there's a lot of damage down
there so that's why it's very very
important that we have a a decisive
president who takes the initiative and
sends tremendous relief to Ukraine
oh my gosh yeah the billions of dollars
over there it's gonna do it's gonna be
great for all of the uh suffering
Americans because you know while they're
down in Florida looking at their lives
being completely destroyed in their
hearts they will be warmed knowing that
ukrainians have guns well that's that's
Equity right yeah I mean it's Global
Equity but it's still Equity right and
also you know surface-to-air missiles
which are finding their way on their
black market so you know that's that's
also really nice to have all over Europe
with fully automatic machine guns also
hitting the black market all over Europe
which is absolutely crazy to send so
much money so much weapons with no
accountability at all thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a mass passive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there